we are happy to continue the
conversation with the Iraqis about what
the right structure is our mission set
there is very clear we've been there to
perform a training mission to help the
Iraqi security forces be successful and
to continue the campaign against Isis to
connect in near the counter - campaign
we're going to continue that mission but
as the as times change and we get to a
place where we can deliver upon what I
believe and the President believes is
our right structure with fewer resources
dedicated to that mission we will do so
we also have today NATO team that's here
at the State Department working to
develop a plan which will get
burden-sharing right in the region as
well so that's what the Secretary of
State had to say a little earlier let's
bring in Osama bin Javed he's joining us
from Baghdad any more clarity on what
the Iraqi parliament does next quadrant
we'll wait to see what the Iraqi
parliament has to say is it is going to
meet in a few hours on Saturday morning
but it is a very interesting point that
the US Secretary of State made that they
will continue their presence and fight
against ISIL which is a big question
mark because since Soleimani
assassination the coalition's efforts
against ISIL the NATO's mission against
ISIL
all of it remains suspended there are no
military campaigns by the coalition
which are being run right now against
ISIL and the Iraqi Prime Minister made
that clear and the last time he spoke to
parliamentarians on Sunday saying that
if the u.s. coalition came in 2014 when
Iraq asked for help against ISIL
now the threat has diminished now the
nature of the threat has changed and
since the events of Friday after
Soleimani
and abimael Mohandas were assassinated
these forces are having to protect
themselves and Iraqi forces will have an
additional responsibility to protect
them as well in something which they
cannot take on and according to the
iraqi prime minister only way forward is
for foreign troops to leave this is
something that he made clear not just to
his Parliament but also to the US
ambassador and according to the handout
we were given by the prime minister's
office to the Secretary of State as well
where he asked that United States should
send a delegation so that the mechanism
of the draw can be worked out and
according to the secular state
that is not something that we will be
discussing so it goes to show that an
important ally who has been in - in the
case of Iraq has been and defeated an
invasion from the United States
essentially where it forced the United
States to leave in 2011 it's asking the
United States to leave again but the
u.s. is adamant that is not going to do
so it is interesting that he mentioned
in my Pompeo that he is going to be
talking about how to expand and further
involve other parties to this conflict
in Iraq and to further the fight against
ISIL and he has spoken to his Canadian
counterpart as well where the United
States president has been criticizing
NATO on one hand he is also hinted at a
wider NATO role as if there is a
possibility of reducing US troops in
Iraq again we'll wait and see until
Saturday morning when Iraq's Parliament
reconvenes whether it's going to discuss
that or not okay Osama thank you for
that update from Baghdad well here's how
the numbers break down there are nearly
six thousand US troops operating between
western Iraq and northern Syria at the
time of the u.s. invasion in 2003 there
were at least a hundred and seventy
thousand American troops deployed in
Iraq by 2007 they began withdrawing as
president george w bush faced criticism
at home and calls to bring the troops
home in december 2011 the last US troops
left under an agreement with the Iraqi
government but just five years later in
2016 at least 5,000 troops are once
again deployed to fight against ISIL
this means a key is an attorney in the
former chief of communications for the
mission of Iraq to the United Nations
she says there's a lot of posturing from
both sides but it's unlikely that
American troops will leave Iraq there's
the United States claiming victory
there's Iran claiming victory and then
there's Iraq which is trying to maintain
its sovereignty but also some face in
front of the in front of the Iraqi
people I believe that the u.s. obviously
is very hard to know what's gonna happen
right now because things are moving very
quickly but the US government is likely
to stay in Iraq when they pulled out in
2011 it only took a few years for Isis
to take
over the second-largest city in in Iraq
and that was a disaster
not just for Iraqis but also for the
u.s. and Iran so we do need US presence
as Americans in Iraq and so did the
Iraqi people
so what we're probably going to see now
is a little bit more posturing from the
people of Iraq a little bit more
rhetoric to appease the Iranian
government which is so so heavily
overseeing the Iraqi government but
overall and ultimately the US government
cannot afford to pull out of Iraq and it
cannot afford to hand Iraq over to Iran